well going back now i understand you
would maybe had plans to become a
carpenter that was maybe something that
you thought
you would be doing is that right where
you know you're toward the end of your
college
well i actually had applied to the
university of virginia in an mba program
i was an economics major at auburn and
that was good for going to graduate
school not good for anything else
and i had applauded i'd been up for an
interview i
honestly doubt i would have ever been
accepted there they had really really
really smart people applying and i i
could do the work but i would i didn't
have the credentials
um
and
but when that offer came up i called and
said may i reapply in two years or a
year you know and they said yeah
you can
um but what happened was when i got here
the only way i could make a living was
as a carpenter my gran my grandfather
been a brick mason so we were okay with
our hands our family was okay with our
hands
and i started you know working as a
carpenter and construction worker and
stuff like that
and then got you know better at it over
time and supported myself in new york
you know as a carpenter and a bicycle
messenger
and so that's how the carpentry part of
it came in and i was like because acting
is it's you know this it's so hard
to to kind of see what you're doing you
don't you can't see what you're doing i
mean you can see it in reflection later
but you can't when you're doing it
carpentry is wonderful because the
tolerances are so specific
it's a great anecdote you know to to
what we do i think and it and it it
forces you to be specific and that's not
a bad thing for an actor either so
you